most of the time right these these
[ __ ] restaurants the ones that are
like the super high end you feel so
[ __ ] out of place because you're not
like an oligarch from russia i don't
feel like i belong there i want to go to
the place that has a cool vibe yeah the
food's a little more uh pricey than
going into like a yachts
you know it's like a you know a little
bit more you get a vibe you have a chill
time there's no expectations you don't
have to worry about how you've been
dressed that's the vibe i like it's a
nice time i just want to have my
12 burger that's like it's better than
mcdonald's but it's it's got a little
gourmet but it's it's not it's not
gourmet but but they put avocado on it
or something i don't know i don't know
just that middle price point is my
comfort zone i'm like this is nice
i just want to feel like the cooks and
the chef care about their food yeah i i
think that's a big thing for me yeah
when i order a drink and they ask me if
it tastes okay before they serve it to
me that's when i feel like i'm out of my
depth i'm like i i've never done this
before i ordered the thing you give me
the thing is our michelin star water for
your knees if i order a wine just give
me the wine um even if i told you even
if i told you it doesn't taste good you
should just be you should just laugh at
me and be like yeah well that's that's
you you did like it it's the small
things if i get served food and
like they come to and ask like oh how
was it was it good i'm just like you
know what you know you care enough to
like care about my opinion i meant as in
like they're going to take it back if i
say no yeah no i'm not like am i
enjoying it
but that's the kind of restaurants that
you know when they bring out the dish or
whatever and you look at and you're like
what is this and then a light novel
title of explanation starts right and
it's like i
can i just eat it
it's like two bites i would be done by
the time you finish explaining this and
i wouldn't care otherwise you know
those are the ones where i'm like if i
said if they came up to me and they were
like was it any good and if i
hypothetically said no then they would
be like what can we do to to help you
because like what the experience i
remember was during the cycling special
where we uh went to that restaurant with
that grandma who was basically just like
eyeballing us
as we were watching pretty much pulled
up a chair and sat with us
it was like you aren't feeding you yeah
yeah exactly
i love that place though it's just cause
like when when someone cause because i
get it because like when you cook a meal
for someone and they enjoy the and they
enjoy the food and anything that tastes
good like there's such a there's like
such a rush to that right and i i feel
like i feel like i've seen enough chefs
who you know obviously obviously it is a
job you know i understand some people
just do it for a job but there's just
there's just some magic to a chef or a
cook who cooks the food and just gets
such an enjoyment
from seeing people enjoy their food
right because
i don't know it's it doesn't just it's
this is this isn't just chefs but you
know if i just see someone enjoying
their job that just makes my day better
you know you know even if you just go to
a [ __ ] mcdonald's and you see like
that one person with a genuine smile and
you're just like you know what good for
you man you you're you're having a good
time working mcdonald's i'm [ __ ]
happy i don't know man if it wasn't
mcdonald's i'd be like oh someone's uh
someone's getting caught because you
ordered a smile god
which was should i get a smile for some
reason on ubereats in japan at the
bottom of the page where you can order
all the stuff there is a muksmile option
for zero yen and i don't understand how
you would purchase said mcsmile because
i'm not there to see the smile
genuinely go to yeah because in japan
you if you a day is ruined yeah it is a
lie in japan if you go into a mcdonald's
restaurant and you say can i get a smile
please then they'll give it to you so
but yeah
and i was fine with that right i don't i
don't agree with that i don't think
someone should have to smile
but
why the [ __ ] why the [ __ ] on ubereats is
it listed when how is the uber delivery
guy get a smartphone i don't know
because i don't even see him because
they have the [ __ ] drop it off at my
door opposite just [ __ ] like take
take like an instamax
the [ __ ] uber driver just takes a
picture of the mcdonald's employee just
smiling like i don't understand why uber
added this to the menu i'm like what for
what i don't understand how this is
going to work i added it one time and
nothing happened because it's legally
part of the mcdonald's menu because
obviously nothing is going to happen
when i ordered the mcsmile via ubereats
because what would happen i was just
curious is this is this a japanese thing
yeah they would never work in the uk
they would
employees would quit on the spot they'd
be like i'd rather die than smile
it's like yeah you want a smile please
order it yeah yeah yeah
it's like an actual menu item poor
workers being forced to smile upon
requests
at least give them like a tip or
something you know you can't tip you
can't say you can't tip here so what's
the reason for smiling oh it's because
the customer ordered me to smile smile
enjoy your job
i want someone to encourage me as i
order these 30 nuggets
that will inevitably destroy my body
well what i enjoy seeing someone smile
without me having to order them to smile
you know just just but in japan you're
like you don't know if they're doing it
because they have to do it yeah japan is
the master of business smiles at the end
yeah i don't know i i feel like i've
been to enough places some places in
japan where i'm just like okay this is
this is like the corporate smile and
we're watching yeah because there's no
way if you turn up like half drunk to a
mcdonald's that they are happy to see
you there like stumbling ordering a a
cheeseburger you know what i mean like
there's there's no way anyone is happy
about it do you think i'm gonna smile
without police
all right i see mates in hockey harbor
and guys i don't think they're really
happy to talk to the customers i don't
know man maybe they're just not excited
to talk to the people that they seem
like they want to do you know you know
when you watch someone smile but their
eyes aren't smiling that's all that
means in our camera
like they sound so chipper
and you know they have a big smile on
their faces they're waving to you like
this but deep in their eyes it's just
yeah
all that industry is also dying yeah you
can't be too happy about that i mean
there's like significant amount less of
major um stores or cafes
but now they all have master on so
they're probably not even smiling
how can you how can you tell if they're
smiling now they've perfected the i
sound happy without smiling voice you
know
nico knee
good they shouldn't have to smile yeah
i'm all for people not needing to smile
that's all right i wasn't going to go
into those many cafes anyway so don't
worry about it
really cherry really i've been to one
it's [ __ ] sucked wow yeah i've been
to one as well yeah we've established
many times on this podcast that they are
the worst thing
have you been on uh no i don't i don't
need to go to want to know i don't want
to get it i i'm violently uncomfortable
but it's an experience you should just
try to know because i know it's so
uncomfortable it's like the most
unbritish thing on earth and i can't i
can't do it i can't like i i've seen
like i saw like offline tv went to one
and i'm like i can just only imagine how
awkward this was when they were in there
like this is terrible i would go back
solely for the reason to take chris with
me i would that that would be an amazing
video that's what i want to do there's a
lot of things i would do just to make
chris suffer
and to make myself suffer as well
can i take you and crystal main cafe
sure sure we'll see how we'll see how
you guys react to that sure why not
trash taste made cafe special that's
probably promise
chris's reactions often are off camera
are almost funnier than his on camera
because
[ __ ] that was [ __ ] connor why'd you make
me do that see chris you're like the
love love beam or whatever i can't
remember what they say about it
[Laughter]
i want to see chris do that has gotten
to the point where she's the most
entertaining miserable british man like
he's so funny to watch be miserable
because he's perfected the art of like
you don't feel bad for making him angry
yeah you know what i mean yeah like some
people when they get upset or
uncomfortable you're like you feel sorry
for them but chris has perfected the way
of like you'd like he's just you just
just don't feel bad for laughing at
chris but he's he's the only man that
can somehow laugh while having a friend
oh yeah exactly
you don't like but that's what's so good
about being british that people don't
feel bad for laughing at you when you're
uncomfortable yeah
because people just like they're like oh
he's having a horrible time it's funny
like like to me with maid cafes like to
me it's the perfect determiner to see if
someone's like a lost soul when it comes
to differentiating between like anime
and real life yeah because if you go to
like if you go to like a maid cafe and
you don't feel uncomfortable then to me
that makes it that that makes me feel
like
he's a lost soul right now because
because like
because maids are meant to act like
anime characters right and there's
nothing more uncomfortable to me than
seeing like a real life anime character
like right in front of my art well
because in real life it's like extremely
uncomfortable to see somebody talk that
way it's like yeah please just because
people do not talk about that just act
normal please
please just i don't know slap me or
something i don't know anything but this
just talk to me like a human being